>> Laura: THE HOLIDAYS CAN BE
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR THOSE
WHO’VE LOST A LOVED ONE,
ESPECIALLY THE CHILDREN OF OUR
FALLEN SERVICE MEMBERS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND
ARROYO IS HERE WITH ME NOW FOR A
LOT MORE.
>> LAURA, EVERY YEAR THE
GARY SMITH FOUNDATION HOSTS A
SPECIAL TRIP THAT CAPTURES THE
SPIRIT OF CHRISTMAS.
LAST WEEK, I JOINED THESE GOLD
STAR FAMILIES, GARY, AND THE
SNOWBALL EXPRESS TO DISNEY WORLD
FOR AN UNFORGETTABLE FIVE DAY
EXPERIENCE.
ONE THAT HOLDS LESSONS FOR ALL
AMERICANS.
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THIS VIDEO
THAT WENT VIRAL LAST WEEK.
THE NASHVILLE AIRPORT CAME TO A
STANDSTILL WHEN TRAVELERS PAUSED
TO SING THE NATIONAL ANTHEM IN
THE CONCOURSE.
♫
♫ ♫
>> ♫ O SAY, DOES THAT
>> ♫ O SAY, DOES THAT ♫
♫ STAR SPANGLED
♫ STAR SPANGLED ♫
♫ BANNER YET WAVE
♫ BANNER YET WAVE ♫
>> THEY WERE HONORING FALLEN
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN.
THIS YEAR, AS IT HAS FOR THE
LAST 13, THE SNOWBALL EXPRESS
SPONSORED BY THE GARY GARY SMITH
FOUNDATION AND AMERICAN AIRLINES
HAS TAKEN MORE THAN 1,000
CHILDREN OF THE FALLEN FROM 87
CITIES ON A CHRISTMAS TRIP
FILLED WITH JOY, FAMILY, AND
REMEMBRANCE.
THEIR DESTINATION WAS
DISNEY WORLD.
>> EVERY ONE OF THESE CHILDREN
HAVE LOST A PARENT IN MILITARY
SERVICE.
WE WANT TO FOCUS ON THESE KIDS.
WE WANT TO BRING THEM TOGETHER
IN THIS HEALING ENVIRONMENT AND
ALSO ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A LOT OF
FUN WHEN THEY ARE DOING IT.
>> IT’S BEEN REALLY FUN.
AND I LIKE HOW WE GOT TO GO ON
ALL THE RIGHT TO DISNEY WORLD.
BECAUSE THIS IS MY FIRST TIME AT
DISNEY WORLD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♫
♫ ♫
>> LOT OF GRATITUDE.
IT WAS AMAZING AT DISNEY.
IT WAS SUPER SPECIAL.
>> STEPHANIE COLLIER, HERSELF A
WAR VETERAN, LOST HER HUSBAND TO
PTSD ONCE HE RETURNED HOME.
SHE HAD HER THREE CHILDREN
JOINED THE SNOWBALL EXPRESS
ANNUALLY.
>> THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH A LOT
OF A YOUNG AGE.
SHE WAS ONLY TWO MONTHS OLD WHEN
HER FATHER PASSED.
IT WAS HARD.
IT’S BEEN A HUGE CHANGE.
THE SMILING FACES.
>> FOR A MOMENT, GRAVE HAS BEEN
REPLACED WITH TALK OF A FAVORITE
RIDE.
>> THE RIDE WE WENT ON.
THE DINOSAUR RIDE.
I LOVE THAT.
>> WHAT’S YOUR FAVORITE?
>> MELISSA’S HUSBAND DIED A
MONTH AFTER THEIR DAUGHTER WAS
BORN.
MELISSA SEES THIS EXPERIENCE AS
AN IMPORTANT ONE FOR HER
DAUGHTER AND ALL THE KIDS HERE.
>> HAVE FUN AND LET GO AND HAVE
FUN AND ENJOY THEMSELVES.
WHICH IS REALLY NICE BECAUSE
THEY ALL HAVE QUITE A BURDEN
EMOTIONALLY TO BEAR THROUGHOUT
LIFE.
SORRY.
SO I JUST THINK IT’S REALLY
SPECIAL TO GIVE THEM THIS
MOMENT.
>> IT CAN BE, ESPECIALLY WHEN
>> HOLIDAYS CAN BE A ROUGH TIME.
SOMEONE IS ALWAYS MISSING.
>> THERE WAS ONE SPECIAL AREA AT
THE ABSENT DADS AND MOMS WHO
THE RESORT SET ASIDE TO REMEMBER
BROUGHT THEM TOGETHER.
IN BETWEEN THE FUN AND THE MIRTH
TO BE HAD, THESE FAMILIES TAKE A
MOMENT FOR REMEMBRANCE.
THESE 650 FLAGS REPRESENT THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE FALLEN IN
THE LINE OF DUTY OR WHEN THEY
RETURN HOME.
THESE FAMILIES TAKE A MOMENT IN
THIS ROOM OF REMEMBRANCE TO
MOURN THEM.
>> WHEN I WALKED IN, I WAS
SPEECHLESS.
IT’S AMAZING WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE FLAGS AND YOU REALIZE THAT
IT REPRESENTS THE PARENT OF
EVERY CHILD THAT IS HERE.
ALSO THAT THIS IS JUST A SMALL
BIT BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHERS.
THAT HAVE LOST A FAMILY
MEMBER, AND IT’S JUST
OVERWHELMING.
YOUR SPEECHLESS.
IT’S VERY EMOTIONAL.
MY DAUGHTER DID NOT KNOW HER
FATHER.
HE WAS THE FIRST MARINE CASUALTY
AFTER THE START -- POST 9/11.
SHE WAS ONLY EIGHT MONTHS OLD
WHEN HE DIED.
JUST GOING THROUGH LIFE WITHOUT
KNOWING YOUR FATHER, JUST
HEARING STORIES.
BUT BECOMING A PART OF SNOWBALL,
AND MAKES YOU REALIZE AND IT
MAKES HER REALIZE THERE ARE A
LOT OF CHILDREN HERE WITHOUT A
FATHER.
YOU DON’T FEEL ALONE.
>> THE SHARED EXPERIENCE BONDS
THESE GOLD STAR KIDS AND ALLOWS
THEM TO ESTABLISH CLOSE TIES.
>> IT’S BEEN AWESOME EXPERIENCE
FOR ME.
OVER THE YEARS, I DON’T GET TO
ACT LIKE HOW I DO NOW DUE TO THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE WOULD MAKE FUN
OF ME.
>> WHAT WE TAKE BACK WITH YOU TO
ARIZONA?
THE GULF PROBABLY JUST SPENDING
A BUNCH OF TIME WITH OUR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
THE BEST THING IS JUST MEETING
NEW PEOPLE AND MAKING NEW
FRIENDS.
>> THEY FEEL LIKE THEY ARE NOT
ALONE.
CHILDREN WHO LOST PARENTS.
JUST TO KNOW THERE’S SO MANY OF
THEM THAT’S GOING THROUGH THE
SAME THING THAT THEY ARE
EXPERIENCING.
AT SUCH A YOUNG AGE, YOU KNOW,
THIS HELPS THEM.
>> I MADE A LOT OF FRIENDS AND I
THINK IT’S SUPER SPECIAL THAT
THEY DO THIS FOR US.
I LOVE IT HERE.
EVERY YEAR, WE COME.
WE MAKE NEW MORE AND MORE
FRIENDS AS WE COME.
IT’S BEAUTIFUL.
>> THESE TWO GIRLS MET AT THE
AIRPORT IN CALIFORNIA AND STUCK
TOGETHER FOR THE ENTIRE FIVE
DAYS.
>> I JUST SAW HER AT THE AIRPORT
AND SHE LOOKED LIKE SHE WAS MY
AGE.
SO I WAS LIKE.
>> I HEAR SHE WAS FILLING
SOMETHING OUT.
>> SHE WAS DOING COLLEGE GAPS.
SHE IS A SENIOR LIKE ME.
>> FOR US AS MOMS, IT GIVES US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BOND.
IT’S A REALLY GOOD SUPPORT
SYSTEM FOR US AS WELL.
>> THIS YEAR, I MET A NEW
FAMILY.
IT’S THEIR FIRST YEAR.
SHE DIDN’T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
THINGS THAT WILL HELP HER
THROUGH HER GRIEF, AND I HELPED
HER THROUGH THIS WHOLE TIME.
SHE’S BEEN WITH US THIS WHOLE
TIME, AND HER DAUGHTER.
SHE TOLD ME, SHE TOLD ME THAT
HER DAUGHTER REALLY HADN’T
TALKED ABOUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED
WITH HER FATHER WITH ANY OTHER
CHILDREN.
TO COME HERE AND WATCH THEM HOLD
HANDS AND GO THROUGH THE PARK
TOGETHER, THAT’S THE STUFF THAT
YOU -- NOBODY ELSE ON THE
OUTSIDE REALLY GETS TO SEE.
THESE KIDS WHO LOST A DAD, THEY
DON’T SEE WHAT THEY ARE FEELING.
THIS, BEING IN THE MILITARY,
LIFE IS HARD AND LOSING SOMEONE
IS VERY HARD.
>> EVERY SNOWBALL EXPRESS ENDS
WITH A SPECIAL CONCERT BY GARY
SINISE AND HIS LIEUTENANT.
THIS YEAR WAS NO EXCEPTION.
>> I WANT A ROUSING APPLAUSE FOR
GARY SINISE.
GARY SINISE AND THE BAND TO BEEN
PLAYING FOR SNOWBALL EXPRESS FAM
PLAYING FOR SNOWBALL EXPRESS FAL
PLAYING FOR SNOWBALL EXPRESS FAY
SINCE 2007.
EVENTUALLY TAKING THE ENTIRE
PROGRAM UNDER THE WING OF HIS
FOUNDATION.
♫
♫ ♫
WHAT DO YOU THINK AS YOU WATCH
THESE FAMILIES RECREATING AND
FORGETTING ABOUT THEIR LOSS FOR
A LITTLE BIT I’M FINDING THAT
CAMARADERIE WITH ONE ANOTHER?
>> IT’S WONDERFUL TO SEE THEM
SMILE.
THAT’S THE WHOLE THING FOR ME.
JUST TO MAKE THESE KIDS HAPPY.
YOU LET THEM KNOW THEY ARE LOVED
AND APPRECIATED.
THEY GET A LOT OF LOVE AND A LOT
OF SUPPORT, AND IT’S EMOTIONAL
FOR THEM TOO BECAUSE THEY ARE
ALL THINKING ABOUT THE REASON
THAT THEY ARE HERE.
THAT’S WHY WE DO IT IN DECEMBER.
IT IS A TOUGH TIME FOR CHILDREN
THAT HAVE LOST A PARENT.
WE SHOW THEM THAT WE ARE NOT
FORGETTING.
WE REMEMBER.
WE DON’T FORGET.
THAT CAN CARRY THEM INTO THE
NEXT YEAR WITH A NEW SENSE THAT
HEY, I’M IMPORTANT.
WHAT I’M GOING THROUGH IS
APPRECIATED.
IT’S NOT BEING FORGOTTEN.
AND THAT THERE ARE OTHERS.
I’M NOT ALONE IN WHAT I’M GOING
THROUGH.
IT’S A BEAUTIFUL EVENT.
I’M SO PROUD THAT WE CAN SUPPORT
IT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: THAT’S THE BEST
THING ON TELEVISION TONIGHT.
GREAT JOB ON THAT.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT.
I WAS CRYING.
MAKEUP, MAKEUP.
SPEAK WITH THE GARY SINISE
FOUNDATION SHOULD REALLY BE
CONGRATULATED.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE GIFT.
I DID NOT ASK LIKE TO HEAR THE
STORIES OR WITNESS THIS.
>> Laura: TO SEE THE
CHILDREN’S EYES.
EVERY TIME I SEE ONE OF THESE
CHILDREN IN PAIN OR A SPOUSE IN
PAIN, I THINK OF HOW WE ARE SO
BLESSED TO LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
I AM ALSO RIGHTEOUSLY ANGRY AT
PEOPLE WHO DON’T APPRECIATE AND
TO PUT ON MASKS AND INSULT
MARINES IN PUBLIC OR WORSE AND
DON’T APPRECIATE ALL THE
WONDERFUL THINGS IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> THESE FAMILIES AND THESE KIDS
CARRYING ON, THESE ARE HEROES
DESPITE THE LOSS.
IT’S A HEAVY BURDEN THEY CARRY.
IT’S ALSO A REMINDER OF THE HIGH
COST OF OUR FREEDOMS, LAURA, BUT
I THINK WE FORGET.
I WAS SURPRISED TO LEARN FROM
GARY AND THE FAMILIES THERE THE
HIGH NUMBER OF SERVICEMEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE PLAGUED BY PTSD
ONCE THEY COME HOME.
THE 20 MEMBERS OF OUR ACTIVE AND
VETERAN MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY
COMMIT SUICIDE.
WE NEED TO STAND WITH THEM
PARTICULAR THIS TIME OF YEAR,
THESE FAMILIES.
GOD BLESS THEM.
THESE KIDS WERE INCREDIBLE.
THE GARY SINISE FOUNDATION.
>> ARE THERE OTHER CELEBRITIES
WHO HELP HIM AND DO EVENTS?
>> THE MEMBERS OF HIS BAND BUT I
DON’T SEE TOO MANY OTHERS LINING
UP, AND THEY SHOULD.
>> Laura: I WISH I COULD PLAY
AN INSTRUMENT.
[LAUGHS]
I WOULD GO.
>> WE CAN GO ON TOUR.
>> Laura: IT WOULD BE NICE.
RIHANNA AND ALL THESE PEOPLE,
THEY DO STUFF, THEY DO TERRIBLE
THINGS.